[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
sunglow here in big no utah my name is
bessie stewart and today we're going to
make our famous pickle pie
pickle pie is a dessert it's not the
sweetest pie we have but it is the
most original took a lot of imagination
i think to invent a dessert pie with a
pickle in it the original owner found
the recipe in a magazine she didn't like
the recipe at all so she changed it
around and now the pickle pie is the
very best as far as i know we are the
only place that makes the pickle pie
[Music]
in pickle pie you will find sugar butter
milk eggs lemon extract corn starch
cinnamon nutmeg and of course the
pickles
so we've got this all mixed in really
nice and smooth so now we're going to
pour it into our unbaked pie shell
to put in the oven
scrape the edges so you get all the
flavor and this one right here
is one that we baked this morning
wow
pickle pie
this is delicious
a little tiny bit of cream on it just
gives it that little bit of sweet and
sour that you need to set off the taste
buds
so
[Music]
the customers like the pickle pie but i
think the biggest selling point is
curiosity
this looked like a delicious pie it
tastes very similar to a pumpkin pie
it's got a
it's not like overpowering or anything
good flavor kind of sweet a little sweet
it's like super sweet it's
not
really sweet
i think it's going to sell
bricknall is a very small little town we
are about three hours from salt lake
city and you don't have to live in a
great big city to have good food you
have to have pride
and an imagination
it's more than just a pie
it's your work of art it's something
that you have done
and it looks pretty and it tastes good
and you can be proud of it